express d times 4 d to the fourth to the
one-half power as a radical expression
so the key thing to realize here is that
if i take anything if i take anything to
the one-half power by definition this is
the same thing as taking the principal
root of that anything so let's just
apply that here we have 4d to the fourth
raised to the one-half power so this
part right over here let me do two
different colors so i have d right over
there and then i have four d to the
fourth raised to the one-half power
which is which by definition is the
principle root the principal root of
four d to the fourth and we explore in
other videos why this all works out well
with
exponent properties and we know how to
simplify this right here we're looking
for the principal root of let me write
this this way this is the same thing
this is the same thing as d times the
principal root of four
times the principal root of d to the
fourth
times the principle root of d to the
fourth the principle root of four
principal root of four is two and we
have that d out front and the principal
root of d to the fourth power is the i
guess you could view it as the positive
square root of do the four and that is d
squared and we don't have to put an
absolute value here because even if d is
a negative value d squared will still be
a positive value if this was a d squared
here then we would have to think about
the absolute value right over here and
then just to simplify this we have a d
times a 2 times a d squared that's
multiply the d's times each other same
base that becomes z to the third so this
becomes two times
d
to the third
power now another way you could have
done this is to just straight use the
exponent properties you could have said
that that is the same thing as d times
and inside the parentheses if you if you
take the product of things and then
raise them to an exponent that's the
same thing as raising each of them
individually to the exponent and then
taking the product so that's the same
thing so i'm going to rewrite this part
right over here as four to the one-half
power
times
d to the fourth to the one-half power
and four to the one-half power this is
literally just the principle square root
of four which is two and d to the fourth
to the one-half power this is again you
can use an exponent property if i have
something raised to some power and then
i have it raised to another power this
is the same thing as
that same base raised to the product of
these powers and we prove it in other
videos so this right over here this
expression right over here is going to
be equal to d
to the
four times one half power what's four
times one half well that's just two
so this simplifies once again a d times
2 times d squared which is 2 d to the
third power